one of the pieces uh that we spent a ton
of time talking about here um is what i
call like the education gap but the way
that it manifests itself is uh you
essentially have this juicing of the
economy or the central bank activities
and there's a portion of the population
you know 50 to 60 of the population uh
that understands whether directly or
indirectly the best way to benefit from
this is to simply own assets don't save
all of your money in cash
try to get some sort of job that they
increase the pay on an annual basis to
combat inflation et cetera but there's
still you know 40 to 50 percent of the
country uh specifically in the united
states they hold no investable assets
and they
live paycheck to paycheck uh save
everything in dollars and they get
really hurt by this and so we get this
widening inequality gap you had this
tweet recently uh that basically was
talking about like the manipulation of
money um to ensure that prices
continually rise but basically it
creates for the vast portion of uh
population this uh kind of modern day
slavery to a monetary system like you
can't get ahead right everything keeps
rising and costs around you uh and
you're just on that rat wheel and you
just can't get off talk a little bit
more about um you know is that a feature
of the system or is that more so a bug
that it's a way to have the kind of fiat
monetary system but not have this
specific negative impact
now so so remember um and this is where
i want to be careful that that a system
will reinforce a system and so it's a
way bigger consequence and and it's easy
to look at people in the system
instead of a system naturally
reinforcing a system i know it's the uh
and why that's important is
it is a feature of this uh system
inflation is theft it's a hidden theft
and that theft enriches some people at
the at the expense of other people
inflation as you said on your last
segment inflation the other side of the
coin is wage and savings deflation
so your real
the wages you're getting are going down
in real terms
and so when you have a small number of
people at the top
um and more people at the bottom and you
drive inflation you're hurting the
people at the bottom more and more and
more and you're enriching the people at
the top
what the people at the top don't see
though as well is
the societal collapse of that
creates kind of the next step of that in
us versus them and revolution comes so
if you look at if you look at germany
in the 30s same thing was happening and
who do you think they're wealthy were
and when what happens next is as a
revolutionary leader comes in
and changes the narrative to say we're
going to take back those assets
and and so
in that environment and what ends up
happening with the wealthy in that
environment too is they think they're
safe because their assets are in hard
assets like real estate and everything
else but those real estates are in the
country
that is that is
creating that
inflation
and those and and because of what
happens next those assets are are
often seized or or or taken back
when you think about uh what people can
do
is it simply just buy assets like the
assets that will benefit from this hold
those assets for a long period of time
and that is the uh kind of escape hatch
for folks um or does that not even work
or how do you think about like what can
people do about this
so
um
and and this is this is where i think
we'll get to bitcoin um and i think that
is the safest asset and it's an
asymmetric bad it's the safest assets
it's the king of all assets in this time
but more importantly than than that um
it's a vote of what you want the future
to look like you i think you i think you
either believe that uh that um
it's okay for a small number of people
to control all others
and and they can print money all they
want and everybody else is a slave
to that system
or
it's not
um and if you believe that it is okay
uh for for that to happen
who should those people be
um because throughout time what people
throughout history
you see people changing their minds
um ego arrogance
humans are
humans change their minds and and i
would do want i want to trust
monetary policy to people who change
their minds and create that
for um and if you kind of play that
forward where things are moving with ai
and robotics i don't want to concentrate
that power in a small number of people
to make decisions over everybody else i
would rather have that decentralized so
prices and what would happen on bitcoin
standard is prices would constantly come
down so it would enable the free market
so prices would so the abundance gained
from technology would be more broadly
distributed
yes it is the primary asset i would own
in today's market because of the safety
you can move it anywhere um and
you're not
so if you remember 12 words you can get
on a plane and go anywhere you want and
there's going to be countries competing
for for for capital and entrepreneurs
the same way they do now on a fiat
system they're going to be competing on
a bitcoin system
so that provides a relative safety for
family wealth gain and everything else
but more importantly
um because the system can't change
itself
you need a phase you need a transition
mechanism to allow you to get to the
other side from an inflationary monetary
policy which might have worked for a
long time
to one that allows deflation which must
be must work
which must be enabled with technology
with where technology is going
when you think about bitcoin
specifically why do you say that it's
superior to all of the other assets is
it something to do with the structure of
it is the sovereignty is it everything
in totality like how do you think
through the various options that someone
has maybe equities real estate other
commodities currencies and bitcoin well
let's let's look at uh
over the last 100 years real estate
would have been the top asset class um
and it's a top asset class
because you can you can lever it
and you can pay back the the debt in
money that's being devalued over time
and and so you you take on debts then
use the system to be able to
pay back debt and cheaper dollars
tomorrow and your asset price rises
now and then if you own 10 houses and
your neighbor owns one
you're richer than your neighbor because
now you can rent those up rents go up
and again with along with inflation as
well if you own 100 houses you you're
wealthier if you're blackstone and
competing against private buyers
in the real estate market you own more
of the wealth
so so
that system and then if you don't own it
at
houses obviously you're a slave to that
to that system working harder and harder
as your rent food everything else is is
going up so you can see the example i'm
making through real estate alone that's
been the top performing asset class over
the last
call 100 years
um next would be
equities but all of those all of those
assets are in the existing system and
being priced in
devaluing dollars and that's not the
that's
one risk those dollars being devalued
and if you think that that's the only
risk then
continue to own
predominantly real estate equities and
everything else because you'll have some
sort of safety in that but that's not
the primary risk that's not the only
risk the other risk is the system
collapse
um
and
bitcoin protects against both both of
those risks um and today it would be
hard to see uh because you don't have
either
in bitcoin there's two network effects
one of the store of value that is
growing the primary kind of layer one
which be would be like investing in the
internet itself tcp ip
um and then layer two on lightning and
such and pump you know a lot about this
but but today if if you put if you
project if you said today where we are
people say well i can't use bitcoin as
as a currency in most places it's hard
or hard to use as a currency
but remember what we do what all
businesses do we we project our current
reality forward
thinking we're projecting the future
instead of projecting the trend of
technology forward and what that will
mean
and what that means and what's happening
on layer 2 and bitcoin is you have two
network effects feeding back against
each other and it will and i i think it
will highly likely to become a currency
that you can use and this and the best
store of value so in
in
first world countries we don't see that
because we've had a system that operates
pretty fairly for a lot of years but if
you're in a third world country like el
salvad salvador and you don't
even the bitcoin is upwardly volatile
it is less risk to use that as a
currency than an exit the existing
currency and so what you see is
lots of other countries starting to use
this as a medium exchange as well
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]